sur les piliers du pont champlain ces
boîtes rectangulaires servent de niveau
faucon pèlerin elles sont fixées en
hauteur comme sur les flancs de montagne
avec en prime de la nourriture à
proximité autour d'un port on a quoi
beaucoup de petits gens auxquels
l'habitant est propice pour eux aussi on
a des oiseaux aquatiques canards et
autres saucisses et une source
d'alimentation pour l'autre en colère et
sous le pont de chantilly et tout le va
et vient et le bruit qu'il impose ne
dérange visiblement pas ses locataires
on planifie les travaux et on planifie
la position des boîtes pour limiter nos
impacts en fait compte sur sur cette
espèce là on a en place des périmètres
de 200 mètres autour du nichoir pour
éviter en fait montre les que les
travaux viennent affecter leur
planification et pour une meilleure
planification
la société a fait appel à une firme de
biologistes pendant la période clé de
reproduction des oiseaux on va on va
faire plusieurs séances d'observation
pour tenter de voir à quel point les
travaux la maintenance du pont peut
déranger ou non l'indication des saisons
ces oiseaux qui sont encore sur la liste
des espèces menacées les boîtes de
nidification installé sous les ponts de
montréal ont permis en six ans
d'enregistrer 33 naissance pour le pont
champlain
c'est une moyenne de trois à quatre
naissances par an lui fauconneau total
qui sont nés cette année donc 4 sur
champlain et 400 honoré-mercier rang et
des beaux résultats a lieu au canada
tous les oiseaux migrateurs sont
protégés par la loi
c'est le cas pour les hirondelles à
front blanc pour qui la société a
installé des nichoirs sécuritaire sous
l'estacade du pont un pont qui
disparaîtra l'année prochaine du paysage
urbain montréalais mais les
constructeurs ont déjà prévu de
déménager les faucons pèlerins sous le
nouveau pont ici à ce mitraillage radio
canada montréal